[Music]
in none of my watch news submitted by
Taiwanese Street food Harry Potter books
were removed from a school library
because they contain real curses and
spells which God Christian rich is a
weird real witch bigot witches are real
we don't want people who practice like
black magic or real witches get stitches
I mean actually witches get switches we
just get which is no joke it's like a
like a like a [ __ ] I was connecting
switches would like tree bark witches
are real though make fun of me if you
want but me and Nikki had a witch on a
podcast and she nailed our lives what if
she used Witkin powers what is it
Wiccan powers I think it's called Wiccan
that's witchcraft yeah boy babies use
Google and just search two guys up no no
I'm not talking about publicly available
information she was talking all kind of
[ __ ] I want to see a bat like real [ __ ]
about our personalized [ __ ] I told her
everything she probably listen to the
podcasts watch JK news noted her
studying no okay tells me this chick
doesn't know how to find JK news yeah
she's not the type she made you believe
okay what you saying gypsies don't watch
JK news I feel like they do their
fortune tellers
I feel like nomads maybe why should I
get newsmen on gypsies I think they do
but going wait so this Catholic school
in Nashville damn Christians yeah that's
the only thing you could say though
[ __ ] Christians
[ __ ] southern baptists I guess that's
true because if you say shoes or
something like that you have a whole
community say muscles that you've been
disrespectful a New York Times editor
just got [ __ ] flamed because he had
some joke about happy jr. on his Twitter
feed from years ago and they're like
he's clearly a self-admitted anti cent
oh my god I mean combat Jew dick ulis
man but because he's New York Times
right well because he's York Times the
right came after him and they're like oh
he says he's a semi in this clearly
joking tweet damn that's [ __ ] up I do
like you he says that he said quote
these books present magic as both good
and evil which is not true but in fact a
clever deception the curses and spells
used in the books are actual curses and
spells which when read by a human being
risk conjuring evil spirits into the
presence of the person reading the text
well they better not be [ __ ] taking
paying attention to cupid and [ __ ] on
valentine's day because it's as little
as baby i put the spell on a [ __ ]
arrow shoots it now you fall in love at
the complete stranger listen here
catholic church stop touching your altar
boys and maybe we can [ __ ] focus on
that first before you go off and talk
about Harry Potter yes I said that he he
he sought advice from Exorcist that he
consulted yes exorcist homies yeah yeah
a lot of churches there's a lot of X
sorry I thought they were possessed I
was the opposite yeah yeah she has a
[ __ ] you know that [ __ ] on Dexter's
the first one she's all like [ __ ]
does the head I thought you went up to
one of those like a magic question
you are the father a pastor father is
all read trust them like that's a
drinking thing or maybe their baby drink
a lot my hammer yeah son nah I take it
back he doesn't look like a little boy
touch her he's cool I think I think he's
okay he's allergic to something I don't
know why he's Cajun oh these are
sunburnt oh [ __ ] you do use tanning in
that outfit just the cloth yeah yeah it
cuts off about here all right so it's
just this one particular school that has
banned Harry Potter series from their
school library they did say that they
that kids can read the books on their
own if their parents get them the books
aren't it's not like they're gonna be
forbidden from reading in the school
it's just that they will not be finding
the Harry Potter series at the school
library I would come dressed like Harry
Potter would have wand every [ __ ] day
just on Twitter they went on who's so
funny
there was this one video of this chick
dancing like she was dressed like
Hermione and she was dancing too like
this like a like EDM sort type of
version of Harry Potter song and she's
just like me in front of the school in
Tennessee that band Harry Potter I
wonder if they have like random searches
for like wands and [ __ ] the kids are
sneaking [ __ ] wands and like during
recess the brooms bringing drama
shoppers that smell and sniff out brooms
yeah they're just creating a black
market for wands and brooms Oh
brooms coming from though okay yeah so
then someone else weeded out if your
child attends this school put them pull
them out immediately if the school
thinks that there are real magic spells
in Harry Potter then it cannot be
trusted to teach your child's real
school life this is the school you want
to put your kids in because it's
actually fishy when a priest is stalking
the school full of kid friendly [ __ ] Oh
get more kids yeah but if they're trying
to put
Andy arcade if they have too much
kid-friendly [ __ ] you know what they're
really trying to do
oh they're trying to [ __ ] kids yes what
Joel alluded to earlier and right now
but that's true
but if if this guy is so kid illiterate
or like I hate kids he doesn't even like
kids you want to [ __ ] them this is why
you can't just look at somebody and
think that people always think that kid
touches are gonna like be like this you
know what I mean yeah like I did a
trolling video years ago that I couldn't
put up because I was kind of sensitive
but basically I was I was out of park
and we put up signs of my face and said
like make sure parents keep on the
lookout for this guy this is my favorite
yeah and then I showed up like six hours
later and I'm walking around all this
[ __ ] like how people think that Travis's
arms though had a bag of candy in a
piccolo and playing my piccolo and then
I would I would put down the bag candy
and a little trail leading to a bush and
all the parents are freaking the [ __ ]
out give their kids bring the card [ __ ]
and it's like come on man you while
there's a camera like this well no the
cameras were in the car actually the
scenes from the fog they're shooting
from inside vehicles yeah so you could
that is hilarious
yeah but the [ __ ] footage is [ __ ]
because Lane [ __ ] orders from the
footage sucks because the cars kept on
parking in front of where we were and so
the footage is like all [ __ ] and it
was some good [ __ ] well not me to say
you my my video my prank I did the same
laws I can never have either
I gotta protect the innocent
so there were these parents that spoke
to Washington Post and so they Ono with
someone else but anyway they shared that
they had been raising concerns about
this father's teaching method since the
fall of 2017 because they say that this
pastor has a fanatical obsession with
the devil and sin and thing and then
they also allows the devil allege that
he had claimed during a school Mass that
pop star Lady gaga made a pact with the
devil for fame and suffers from all this
fun Ryoga as a result it's both crazy
I remember growing up and and going to
church and we used to watch these videos
of how rappers made deals with the devil
and if you play Bone Thugs and harmony
in Reverse you sound like he's still in
that time zone like were like yeah man
rappers the devil drinking the devil
poker and one your friends souls no no
no souls yeah you gotta set up one of
the business manager turn by one or win
one she might win yours too yeah she's
got my back all right you know how we
roll here I try to sell my soul to the
devil and he says not your oh we got a
crowded down here right now I feel like
hell is gonna be like this dope ass club
that's popping and always playing your
favorite song you can't stop dancing but
you can't get the bartender to like look
it away to give us something to drink
laying the whole time oh man this is oh
you run in the back detail okay hey baby
girl
[ __ ] kind of thirsty out here like you
never saw only being a pretty was like
hot water so you never get like
hydrangea I think hell is there playing
country music the whole time and you
have to dance to it
that's my help - I feel like heaven mine
everyone round here idiots and they'll
smile like you know [ __ ] I hate this
[ __ ] yeah that would be hell yeah your
favorite music ah you imagine a person
that loves country music that has
listened to trap music for the rest of
their life Oh see it's like an eternity
of death no but then they win with learn
us no no they don't they don't get that
it's the same song is to say song
forever just then a whole lot of black
dudes around on sagging and flavor
pistols in the air unregistered pistols
sounds like a really nice place why
what's the music you hate you hate
country - no I love all music so I'm
like joke's on you devil I'm a [ __ ]
big-time music lesser you Robert Ellis
do anything I went into looking for
[ __ ] straight-up Aborigine music with
the didgeridoo I wanted to connect with
my [ __ ] indigenous side right so I
was like let's look for something what
if the devil knows that you like music
so he turns the music off let me think
of that huh did he made me deaf the
devil turns music off
silent silent kill Joe silence will kill
Joe sitting down is gonna [ __ ] kill
you back if it's no stimulus that would
kill Joe don't tell him that he's
watching or not
ah or it's a girl telling me a story
about her dream last night and I'm like
and it never said never ends it never
[ __ ] ass that's true I wouldn't mind
[Music]